[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos desde
casa en esta ocasión iniciamos con una
empresa chilena llamada not go que se
destaca por producir alimentos a base de
plantas que reemplacen o replique en
productos con proteína animal los
responsables de la compañía aseguran que
se trata de una forma de proteger al
planeta y añaden que sus alimentos son
mucho más ricos que los originales
hablamos con max silva director del nodo
para chile y países de expansión y esto
fue lo que nos contó no surge con la
necesidad de poder desarrollar productos
que sean muchísimo más eficientes para
el planeta en materia de impacto de
emisiones de co2 y de agua y el camino
para eso esa alimentación en base a
plantas el problema es que alimentación
envasada plantas parece aburrida y
nosotros acá lo que hacemos es
desarrollar productos que sean igual de
espectaculares que los que nos gustan
pero sólo y dejando plantas y para eso
utilizamos inteligencia artificial en
los desarrollos la compañía usa un
algoritmo de inteligencia artificial
propio que equipado con una base de
datos de miles de plantas además de
sistemas que permiten entender cómo
funcionan las proteínas animales esta
mezcla entre el trabajo de la tecnología
y de los expertos permite acelerar el
desarrollo de productos de una forma
mucho más rápida y precisa es una
tecnología desarrollada en la compañía
que se llama giuseppe que lo que hace en
palabras sencillas es determinar qué
plantas y en qué proporción a través de
un proceso industrial pueden reemplazar
la funcionalidad olor textura y aroma de
los alimentos en base a proteínas
animales pero sólo usando plantas
logrando el mismo efecto y por tanto
también logrando la misma experiencia en
las personas la compañía cuenta con
cuatro macro categorías en las que
clasifican sus productos reemplazos en
leches en helados en cárnicos y en
salsas los responsables explican que su
principal objetivo es que sus productos
sean atractivos en cuestión de sabor
para que las personas no tengan que
dejar de consumir lo que les gusta sino
reemplazarlo por alimentos basados en
plantas que son mucho más eficientes
actualmente comercializan en chile
argentina brasil y eeuu y a través de
terceros en mexico colombia y canadá
para 2022 planean estar en el mercado
asiático y en oceanía y para 2023 en
europa vamos ahora a perú donde fue
desarrollada rami una herramienta con
tecnología geoespacial que monitorea vía
satélite y con radar la minería ilegal y
alerta durante todo el año de la
deforestación en la amazonía peruana
este programa analiza la región de madre
de dios considerada la capital de la
biodiversidad en perú el software genera
alertas tempranas de minería y permite
acceder a información en tiempo real de
los cambios en la cobertura forestal
pero la novedad que más resaltan sus
responsables es su capacidad de superar
la limitación que pueden suponer las
nubes por lo que observa los bosques sin
importar los fenómenos climáticos los
365 días del año diferencia con rami que
el tipo de imagen que se está utilizando
es o son imágenes de muy alta calidad
son imágenes de muy alta resolución
también son imágenes que pueden que se
pueden utilizar en cualquier época del
año que eso es una de las cuestiones
claves en esta en esta herramienta
entonces es una tecnología
usada conocida que está combinando se
con un tipo de imagen que nos permite
tener mucha mayor eficiencia a lo largo
del año para poder monitorear este la
actividad minera no con la tecnología
usual solo puedes utilizar esta
herramienta
si es que no tienes cobertura de nubes
por ejemplo que en cambio con esta nueva
tecnología no importa si hay cobertura
de nubes las imágenes de radar pasan las
coberturas de nubes a puede ver lo que
está ocurriendo en el suelo entonces eso
es lo novedoso con esta tecnología
y ahora vamos hasta países bajos donde
científicos están desarrollando una
tecnología láser que permite aplicar
inyecciones que según ellos son
prácticamente indoloras y no requieren
agujas algo que consideran un importante
avance sobre todo para las personas que
sufren de miedos o fobias relacionados a
la tecnología de inyecciones sin agujas
que estamos desarrollando es muy
importante porque al remover la aguja
muchas más personas que tienen miedo de
ser vacunadas van a poder aplicarse el
fármaco en este momento lo logramos al
acelerar pequeñas gotas del líquido que
penetra a la capa superficial de la piel
y esto tiene muchas ventajas primero
eliminamos el miedo pero adicionalmente
contaminamos mucho con las agujas que
son usadas además nuestro sistema inmune
funciona muy bien cuando inyectamos en
las capas superficiales de la piel es
que el artefacto que desarrollan fue
nombrado bajo el gong o pistola de
burbujas y según los investigadores el
proceso es más veloz que la picadura de
un insecto además no causa dolor porque
las terminaciones nerviosas de la piel
no se tocan
de glass en un milisegundo el cristal
que contiene el líquido se calienta con
un láser se crea una burbuja en el
líquido que empuja el líquido hacia
fuera a una velocidad de al menos 100
kilómetros por hora pero pese a los
avances podría tomar entre 1 y 3 años
que este método esté disponible para el
público en general dependiendo del
progreso de investigación y de
cuestiones regulatorias
finalizamos en california donde fue
desarrollado un particular robot bípedo
que tiene la capacidad de saltar a andar
en patineta o caminar en una cuerda
floja se llama lyon y según sus
responsables se trata del primer robot
que utiliza articulaciones múltiples y
propulsores basados en hélices es así
como logra mantener el equilibrio y
realizar movimientos complejos
así llegamos al final de este programa a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
recuerden que pueden repetir esta y
otras emisiones en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]